[Music]
that you fought Roger and MMA rules are
under MMA rules when you're walking out
to enter the Octagon to fight someone
like that and just to flash forward I
mean the this the story as it was retold
to me having seen the footage but as
retold to me by another high-level
jiu-jitsu practitioner he said not only
on the feet
did you effectively beat the [ __ ] out of
Roger but on the ground also you were
able to do that so two questions when
you're walking out are you saying hurry
up and fail to yourself on the way out
to the Octagon no I'm on game day when
I'm putting rounds in my magazines so on
your bot when you put your bottom up
body arm when you put your body armor on
put your helmet on do a combo check do a
what check a combo check like a
communication with a radio on all the
different channels and we have like your
primary secondary contingent and
emergency channels then the very next
thing you do is you chamber around into
your pistol because if you do your rifle
first you'll forget to do your pistol so
you do these things in these pre-mission
checks in a very specific order so you
never miss something so so I'm in a
gunfight with my rifle my rifle runs out
of ammunition
somebody's charging at me I go to
transition I forgot to put a round in
the chamber
like you think you'd never do that but
like you're about to have the
helicopters but getting spun up you know
guys are putting their gear on
you can forget so you do things very
meticulously when I put that round in my
chamber of my pistol before I start
putting the round in the chamber of my
rifle and about which is the last thing
that I do before I start taking tape off
of charges or you know making sure all
my grenades or prep properly when it's
like not today that's what I'm telling
myself like I can fail all the time and
try training I can I can rush to failure
I can hurry up and fail every
opportunity when I'm getting ready but
when finally bullets are gonna fly or
I'm gonna walk into that octagon or I'm
gonna kick that door in not today like
not a [ __ ] chance are you gonna beat
me on that day
is that what you repeat to yourself when
you step into the Octagon and you're
waiting for all the announcing day to
complete or is there more that goes
through your head I'm actually waiting
for the first time I make a mistake and
somebody thinks that they're gonna do
something great you know that like I'm
gonna get hit the first time or in
Hodges case I shot an inside single on
him to put him on his back which nobody
thought in my right mind I would do and
he got my back hundred Gracie's best
position harder Gracie if he gets on
your back you're going to sleep period I
got there and I was like hell yeah do
what's gonna happen I'm gonna get out of
here
I'm gonna start punching you in the face
and think about that what's good that's
gonna do to him psychologically
psychologically I mean the he's in the
best position that he could possibly be
in the thing that he's the best at and
this little Perry handed monkey that's
in front of him gets out and starts
punching him in the face
Dali has his back no he's just that was
the end of the fight I was three minutes
into the fight and there was nothing he
could do psychologically from that point
forward because I already beat the bad
thing he did the best right so even in
my failure I was like hell yeah here I
come you know like I wish I had blood
dripping out of my mouth and sending
them pictures later of it because like
that's that's the opportunity to really
thrive to grow and just scare the
freaking [ __ ] out of somebody yeah
you